- We are back with Melissa McCarthy and
Ben Falcone everybody.
(applause)
That was a look at
their new Netflix series
"God's Favorite Idiot",
and joining us now are their
co-stars from the show.
You know one from Talladega
Nights and Iron Man,
and the other from True Detective
and Veep, say hello to
Leslie Bibb and Kevin Dunn.
(funky jazz music)
(applause)
- Your hair!
- Oh my gosh.
We're gonna have to talk
about your hair for a minute.
- You realize when I...
I just screamed that
(laughter)
when I was in Australia, I did her show,
when I was with them! Yeah!
We were all in Australia, I did your show,
and it was so weird to be
on zoom that far away from you.
So it's so nice to be...
- So you play Satan.
- Yeah, Satan.
- What does one do for
research for that role?
Just, do you read the Bible? Or...
- No, I didn't read.
No. I did read that!
I did look at the demonic book that,
that we referenced this book.
So I did a deep dive.
Cause there's like all these
different words for Satan,
so I looked up...
- Like Lucifer, all those things
- DDD. Demonic deep dive.
- Beelzebub, I think there's a lot of 'em.
- There is a lot! Right?
And so, but I don't know if you're playing
somebody that's so evil,
I don't think evil
people think they're evil
or they're bad.
Right? They think kind
of think they're good.
And so...
- I think they're called
narcissists, but yeah.
(laughter)
- We see them all the time
- All the time!
- They're just out and about.
- So I don't know.
I wanted her to be a little bit like
Tracy Flick in "Election".
- Yeah.
- And I think she desperately
wants like friends.
I think she's obsessed with,
I think she really feels
like she's gonna get Melissa on her side.
She's like, she's like, I could see it.
- Probably.
- And I think she just really wants to be,
like picked for the team.
And I don't think she ever is.
- And then burn you alive.
- And then burn you alive!
- But with a smile!
- She'll turn on you really fast.
- That was a great movie.
Yeah. Can I get you something?
Yeah. Burn you alive.
Light the couch on fire.
- I just think that'd be a more,
like a more fun role to play.
- It's so fun and these
guys let you do anything,
they're so fun to work
for because don't like,
they let you try, anything, right?
- Just we don't have a plan going in.
- Yes you do!
- They're just like do something.
- No, I love that.
But do you think that
y'all do that because you
are those kind of actors,
you like a little bit of,
I mean your whole life is improv,
I think, your children would say.
- I have to say when you have, I mean,
when Ben and I, think when you have like,
people like this,
and we have such a great cast.
- Yeah.
- It's like, here's the roadmap, but like
you don't hire great people and be like
don't do what you do.
Yeah.
- It's very fun, like
going on set and like going
through a scene that you're
gonna go in the next day.
And then like hopping on and then going,
like rehearsing?
It's so ridiculous.
- Yeah, it is.
- Because you, like, you
get halfway through it
and you would just start talking.
- Welcome to my life, Kevin.
- I know. It must be terrible.
- It would just change,
the whole scene would be a different scene
but it was be like,
that's good.
- So you, Kevin, you played Ben's dad.
So do you think that he'd
make a pretty good son?
No pressure in answering, he's right here.
- He was a fine son.
And we covered a lot
of ground in the sauna.
- [Ben] We did.
- Yeah. It was so fun.
I mean, just when we were
talking about setting it up
and when Ben mentioned
it, when he called me,
it's just an odd thing.
I had just finished building a sauna
or was in the throws of...
- Did you say you built a sauna?
- Yeah. That was my
Covid project because...
- Okay. I just love how you
were just like, oh yeah,
and then I built a sauna.
Like that was very flippant.
- [Melissa] The odds are that are like,
they're so crazy.
- It was so weird,
cause it was like, yeah,
I'm doing this thing.
And you know, you play my dad and you,
and we sit in the sauna and talk.
And I said, you know what
I was just doing today?
I was hooking up the
heater, the final heater to
the sauna because there was nothing to do.
I was, there was no work.
We were locked down and
my wife was like, wow.
- [Kelly] You need to do something.
- She had bought me a book about
building a Finnish sauna and said...
- Not inside the house!
- Yeah. Outside. Yes. Outside. Out!
- So, yeah.
- I feel very lazy. I didn't learn,
I didn't build anything
nor did I learn a language.
You built a sauna, and
the first time you said
Finnish sauna I was like,
like a finished project.
And I was like, oh no,
he means like Finland.
- The Finns.
- Like the Finnish.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God, I thought
you, I thought you meant,
I went Tim 'The Toolman' Taylor,
I thought she was like, you
need to actually finish the job.
Like I thought you went there to oh, okay,
like I finish.
- As opposed to a, yeah.
- What makes it Finnish in its
look, versus a normal sauna?
Now I'm curious.
- It's not just, it's
not what the look is,
it's just how it's vented.
- Ooh.
- It's pretty basic.
It's just, you know...
- The Finns, right?
- They're really great with venting.
They know how to vent!